corpos pessoal brindes a mais um vídeo e
hoje vou ensinar como fazer um mar mas
que é uma junção de vários comentários
que vocês têm deixado nos últimos vídeos
o primeiro deles é que alguns sushi e
josé o primeiro gênero documentário é
que algumas pessoas queixaram da
existência das armas que têm feito é tão
pessoal que então fazer uma arma mais
resistentes e outras pessoas disseram
que foi por mais elásticos então mas se
eu fizer o mar mais resistente aí que eu
vou conseguir pôr mais elásticos porque
a estrutura da arma vai permitir e
aguentar uma opção muito maior e outras
pessoas pediram para eu fazer uma capa a
capa 47 e então tentei fazer mais ou
menos possível
claro que não fica muito muito parecido
porque foi atropela cair modo simplista
andar mas aí está o tutorial primeiro
precisa dobrar uma folha ao maio usar
uma folha normal a quatro impressoras a
cair nesta partida vão dobrar de modo
que fique três centímetros da linha do
maio em cada e e para o final da foi ok
vocês podem constatar isso pelos
quadrinhos a verde que depender de mim
que vocês vão ver tem um centímetro é só
fazer o mesmo do outro lado por ficar
assimétrica
veja aqui o marquei para vocês verem
melhor linha fica 90 graus aqui quando
você se sobrepõe uma parte à outra e
vejo aqui com essa carga on-line ea
impressão e vai tudo naturalmente vai
arrancar abertura tem ficar por cima com
aquelas duas partes é muito importante
ficar assim quiser é a única maneira
revistar certo não ficaram tão não tem
que voltar atrás e fazer um novo e do
brasil na partida dá uma resistência
maior porque a história tem que ser
mesmo muito resistente tem que fazer
todas as partes que eu vou acrescentar
que vocês vão ver senão não vai
funcionar o vai ficar o sindicato
estranha é porque eu faço vários modelos
antes de fazer o tutorial final
vejo aqui por lá é a rifa se vamos dizer
tem que fazer é subir e quem ficar mesmo
justo em cima um da fifa
um sábio irregular que mais duas listas
eu fiz outra coisa é pra fazer e colônia
você deve estar familiarizados com este
tipo de crônica que já fiz em algumas
armas mas se você quer fazer uma
campanha maior podem sempre usar folhas
de jornal ou então folha a3 para baa3 a
maior a mais quente é isso que estou
aqui porque aqui é e vai ficar tudo bem
encaixado você tem que usar o mesmo cola
quente neste caso vai ficar muito
resistente
quando você tem que verificar que fica
um sentimento de qualquer coisa em cima
de jéci não ficar não vai haver espaço
para encaixar os elásticos
portanto vocês iam lá embaixo que o cano
dm cima da rifa para ficar mesmo é o
tamanho
veja que o por fita em várias parte
desta chamada de fazer sempre o força da
palavra guerra tem mesmo fazer estas
coisas por força que eu fui depois na
partida o perdedor é porque não fizerem
pois não não vai aguentar quando vocês
forem para o cargo do traje e vão à
guerra naquela partida vai estragar tudo
pronto vai tudo por água abaixo mas
estarmos o mesmo existente aqui sala e
eu já brinquei que é porque sou uma
criança e um adulto criança não sei como
é que isso se diz um dos lados como não
ofender nem tamanho êxito as outras
turmas comentários
mas é isso aí tem por esta fita aqui
muito importante para dar uma
resistência arma é porque já fiz sem
isso e com isso e claramente que isso
aumenta bastante a existência da arma
pronto podem por fita em todos os lados
fita não nos traga são ajuda
agora fazer um escort e fiz um
espaçamento de 0,5 centímetro a cair 0 a
cinco corpos 10 gols em corte e depois
tiram parte impacto não é importante
quando vocês fizerem a conexão aqui e
ali quando fugiam em cima por bastante
cola vai ficar bastante resistente
especialmente nesta parte tem foram
bastante cola quente porque é que vai
ficar os elásticos encaixadas e se não
tiver bastante colo nesta quarta
então vai se entregar até então tem que
usar mesmo na cola na parte de cima da
área
estou fazer outra vez como vocês viram
no início só que não vou fazer aquela
coisa da obra 90 graus para fazer o
carregador está outra vez aquelas três
cêntimos que vocês têm que deixar a
partida do maio e para uma extremidade
da folha mas grupos fitta é e do abraão
maio 20 bem fisicamente e serginho e
para ficará com uma capa pronto é só
cortar ali inclinado um carinho uma
parte vocês vão cortar e outra parte não
quer só depois dobrar para ficar igual à
corte e vejam que eu vou pôr um
pedacinho de fita nessa partida do
triangular
depois é só encaixar na parte de cima da
outra e tem poder com fita outra vez
basta olhar nos encaixar
só que tem que dar uma estrutura que tem
que ficar mais resistente primeiro tempo
daquela corte em cima vai ajudar a tirar
os latics é vocês marca onde é que fica
à parte da crônica e fundar a existência
através com fizeram aparte agarrar a
bola para trás já que ele é coronel
carregador e que eu não sei eu sempre
deixei os comentários porque eu sou uma
pessoa com falta do vocabulário não
custa mais de deus dos produtos ali são
diferentes são uma linha só fiz os
pontos mais quererem podem traçar uma
linha entre os pontos de verão o tamanho
do trinco vocês precisam cortar no final
pode sempre dar mais uma forçada com
fita época ajuda sempre na estrutura
e já está só encaixar o carregador e por
elásticos usuários elásticos aquelas de
fazer pulseiras que estão na moda cair a
gente encontrar um preço muito barato
aí vão pondo sempre do mais longe para
mais perto dos primeiros a encomenda de
forças não temos saem com muita força e
veja só que daí podem fazer vários
carregadores pães e lá sem precisão a
volta pois é só trocar carregam e sempre
brincar e só eu e vocês brinquei mas
usem óculos de proteção tem como se
fosse uma arma nero 1 ayr sofre qualquer
coisa do gênero importante é você usar
em proteção e só os pés amputados vocês
quiserem usar o canal deixem um like e
se inscreva para acompanhar as coisas
que eu faço é isso bateau